aquí tenemos algunos modelos de las
moléculas que podemos encontrar en un
sistema biológico arriba a la izquierda
tenemos el ejemplo de un aminoácido los
aminoácidos son los bloques de
construcción de las proteínas si
observamos que es lo que conforma un
aminoácido veremos esto de color gris
son átomos de carbono los blancos son
átomos de hidrógeno
los rojos representan átomos de oxígeno
y este azul representa un átomo de
nitrógeno podemos ver que muchos de
estos elementos se repiten en los otros
modelos de moléculas en especial el
carbono y el hidrógeno aunque también
vemos bastantes átomos de oxígeno y de
nitrógeno también veremos que el fósforo
aparece en muchas ocasiones en estas
moléculas y esta no es una lista
exhaustiva más adelante veremos otros
elementos pero los que mencionamos son
los que aparecen con más frecuencia por
ejemplo aquí tenemos un modelo de
adenosín trifosfato atp cuando
estudiamos biología vemos con frecuencia
que es el almacén de energía de los
sistemas biológicos de nuevo vemos
muchos carbonos en gris oscuro varios
hidrógenos en gris claro
aquí tenemos oxígeno
en este modelo el nitrógeno está en
color azul claro y luego tenemos los
fósforos en color amarillo este es el
modelo de un triglicéridos también
conocido como una molécula de grasa las
moléculas de grasa se usan para
almacenar energía y de nuevo podemos ver
muchos átomos de carbono en gris oscuro
también tiene hidrógenos y algunos
oxígenos este es un modelo de adn o al
menos un pequeño segmento de un adn y
podemos ver que es una molécula mucho
más compleja en comparación con las
moléculas que vimos anteriormente este
modelo se podría extender más allá del
tamaño de la pantalla en ambas
direcciones pero nuevamente vemos estos
átomos que no son familiares está el
carbono en gris oscuro el hidrógeno en
gris claro el oxígeno en rojo los
nitrógenos en azul y el fósforo en
amarillo aquí lo importante es recordar
que las moléculas biológicas tienden a
estar compuestas de los mismos bloques
de construcción y de hecho esto ocurre
no solamente a nivel elemental sino
también a nivel molecular por ejemplo en
el atp tenemos algo que se conoce como
base de nitrógeno
acá tenemos un azúcar con 5 carbonos y
acá abajo tenemos 3 grupos fosfato en el
adn pasa algo similar tenemos una base
de nitrógeno que no es muy fácil de ver
aquí también tenemos los azúcares con 5
carbonos que tampoco podemos ver bien y
por aquí tenemos algunos fosfatos
de hecho la columna del adn está
compuesta de los azúcares con 5 carbonos
y los fosfatos pero porque aparecen
constantemente estos elementos pues son
elementos muy comunes en la tierra por
ejemplo el nitrógeno es lo que compone
la mayor parte de la atmósfera también
existe mucha agua en la superficie de
nuestro planeta y el agua está compuesta
de hidrógeno y oxígeno el carbono se
encuentra en una pequeña proporción de
la composición de nuestra atmósfera que
es un 0.04 por ciento de esta pero los
organismos fotosintéticos como las
plantas son muy buenos usando el carbono
para guardar energía en sus enlaces y
cuando nosotros comemos plantas estos
enlaces de carbono forman parte de
nuestros cuerpos y para poder apreciar
los elementos que nos conforman tenemos
esta tabla en donde se indica que la
mayor parte de nosotros está compuesta
de oxígeno
se debe a que nuestro cuerpo está
compuesto principalmente de agua y el
agua está formada en su mayor parte de
oxígeno también tenemos hidrógeno y
después del oxígeno está el carbono
también vemos nitrógeno fósforo y calcio
que es lo que forman la mayor parte de
nuestros huesos pero que también se usa
para contraer los músculos y podemos
seguir estudiando otros elementos
básicos en esta lista que son elementos
que veremos constantemente en biología
en resumen aunque los sistemas
biológicos pueden ser muy complejos
todos están formados con bloques de
construcción similares y estos bloques
provienen del medio ambiente en el que
estos sistemas biológicos existen y
evolucionan nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo